oh
now you might think this is a bit of an
excessive reaction
as you can see we're already having a
pretty cramp ass day
sweet lord jesus brought me to the city
of angels
for a purpose yeah
they do grow pretty in texas
you can always work for me you know
working at the club aka selling a bunch
of drugs to la's horniest
crackheads
and i should have listened to you all
the money and all his [ __ ] drugs are
gone okay
find a way to get me that 20 grand back
i know your plates i know your friends
this is a scary drug dealer
that i'm trying to make a good
impression with now i need your help
more than ever
show me that life
you're a [ __ ] badass
[Music]
who are you supposed to tell people we
came to hollywood to start a comment i
haven't seen you before
well look at god just working his ways
do you know where to get waxed around
here
[Music]
always did have flavor for danger
i hate them should i
kill them
[Music]
[Music]
last
so what do i know about you
you